uh
oh
oh
[ __ ] oh
true
oh
get up
don't go that way
oh
oh
[ __ ]
oh
stay tight
right here
oh
oh
oh
oh
are you my gonna
okay
should
oh
up
please
foreign
okay
um
okay
oh
oh
oh
foreign
yes
[ __ ]
experiences
oh
oh
oh
oh
what's the point
oh
okay
oh
thank you
oh
come on
oh
no no
oh
huh
oh
and then
stay in the front line i'm going out in
the back
oh
oh
oh
what
here
you can't oh
oh
oh
okay
i'm going to help
my sister that was my sister your [ __ ]
[ __ ]
we're still here we'll be here
let's go
i
barbie oh my god
that's crazy
i'm out here by myself
oh oh
attacked my sister we was out here
peacefully protesting
these people are soulless these people
are soulless we don't want any more
justice
we don't want no justice [ __ ] justice
we're beyond justice
at this point is at this point is
revenge at this point it's vengeful
at this point we're angry and we're done
first of all look at our neighborhood
have some people from the neighborhood
get gum jobs let them make the money so
they can control our neighborhoods
why are they living in nice
neighborhoods to patrol the hood
look at our [ __ ] look at this [ __ ] we
can't farm here
no the turn the camera look at that can
we farm can we utilize that
that land no everybody so close together
is mental illness there's there's lack
of frills y'all know
some acting like y'all don't know y'all
know they know
how many white people have been murdered
by the police
i can i can't go and start naming
something you name something
you can't you can't we can't name any
white people that have been murdered by
the police
there's a common denominator the common
the common denominator is the color of
the people's skin that they continue to
killing
and the neighborhoods that they choose
to kill in these grids that they keep us
enslaved in
these are grids they know that we're
slaves
my sister we're all here protesting
because we're educated and we can
actually verbalize how we feel
these people cannot handle it i'm out
here
y'all don't see an army behind me
come on man it took a woman it took
women to go up and get into
those police faces all these men were
standing around here doing nothing
as usual it's going to take a modern day
harriet
to make it happen i just got hit i just
got tore up
yes
okay
okay
right
oh
oh
oh
again
oh
oh
there you go
god
oh
oh
get the [ __ ] outta here
watch out
guys
i'm tired of them
come
okay
you
oh
um
oh
hello
watch first
guys
all right
okay
don't think
cool
oh
4500
what are we gonna [ __ ] stop stop
oh
uh
look at
still got
oh
yes
one of these brothers
is
oh
is
but i'm still outside
it's just anger it's just anger
it's not a bullet it's not a bullet it's
just a
it's just a it's what happens
this is what happens when you shoot a
all right
okay
i just look
is
oh
foreign
what
it's like
your salary your salary your salary
your salary your salary yourself
that light ain't doing
okay
is
one
right
what is your name
oh
oh
oh
uh
foreign
oh
oh
oh
cheap
goodness
uh
which way
she says
is
oh
uh
yes
why can't i sit there and get a job
is
people here
hello my name
i'm a is woman and when i saw the young
man being shot and murdered
my son was questioned and the major
question that my son had for the black
cops
that i thought was very important was
why was they punk ass sitting there and
allowed to happen
and for i white people are going to do
what they do
they're going to hate us because by
medically
and scientifically they are mutated
version of us they hate the fact that
they don't have no melody they have no
purpose in life
they have nothing without us and
everything about us that they wish that
they was but they never will be that's
just a scientific fact
i have a degree in microbiology but the
main thing that
bothered me when i saw those two dogs
gunned down that king that not another
person of color said anything
and what these black people understand
you are [ __ ] [ __ ] to them
they talk about you they go home
foreign
[ __ ]
is
white ass bliss
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh
me
oh
times like this so you're like a pretty
face they got coming out with everything
basically
we're just here to make sure that you
know
you can do it the right things
excuse me
oh
is
is
can you become a part of our community
by relating to it y'all have a community
relations officer
that can come over here and relate to
the community i live on 54th america
i was helping people doing the corona
virus doing my last riot
and i'm not an officer i'm the next
convict
that's not even my job that's your job
so look you feed attention
to a personal conversation going on in
the front line
but you refuse to talk to everybody
a
six hours
how many people are here
bye
oh
you have the opportunity to speak to
these people
and will you take this opportunity
that's our law
i will bring the bike to you my court is
a hundred feet
i i will take my chains off and cross
the line
bring me to
is
you know
eventually somebody crossed the line and
that's great
that's gonna be the justification for a
riot out here
it's 20 million people watching on tv
waiting for you so to get to the back
they'll give them a [ __ ] [ __ ]
about murder
[ __ ] get paid to be
you got an american flag on your face
officer
red green blue birthplace of america
philadelphia
oh
oh
yesterday
the police
now why i could say that you know
is
is
departure
you wanna hurt me right
when one of your loved ones get gunned
down are you going to have that same
energy
are you going to go to work and put
because you know that your black baby
don't mean
[ __ ] to your white colleagues you're
still a [ __ ]
you still make sense to them and
understand this
whether you want to
then
black lives matter
with your white house
oh
okay
but you feel comfortable the [ __ ]
standing in my face when i [ __ ] shoot
a [ __ ] shield
okay
yes
you
me
oh
all right
oh
what
i can't imagine
i'm
no they decided so they left the bikes
okay
is
go to work
um
is
did y'all hear what she said say it
so don't be
oh
uh
true
hello
um
oh
thank you for not running this over
you